日本の人口の99.99%日本人である
そのうちの8割は20代の女性でその8割のうちの75%は練習を積んだ細身の
バレリーナで残りは健康美に輝く看護婦とモーニング娘や akb48などといた
アイドルグループのメンバーである
国民のほとんどは外国人を見たことはおろか
町で見かけたことすらない
そのため多くの女性はいここの男性にばったりで会おうと途端にひざまずいて毎晩お
寿司を握ってあげるから私を妻にして
と懇願する
興奮のあまり思わず男に飛びついてしまう者も少なくない
こういった絶え間ないナンパ攻撃を退けるために
外国人男性はみんな普段からバットを持ち歩く
インターネットの情報はいつも希望に満ち溢れているとしかし残念ながら現実はそうで
もない
2012/03/24僕は親友の結婚式に参列するために一週間ほどの予定でアメリカ
に変えた
以下はその日僕が大分の田舎にある自宅を出てからシアトルの空港に着くまでの記録で
あるそれと同時にり品
在住の外国人男性が日々無言で立ち向かっている本当の恐怖についての文書でもある
8:45am 大分県の同意中にある三重町の駅でこれからの長旅盗ま得てモンスター
への字をすすりながら僕は今にも壊れてしまいそうなプラスチックベンチに座って大分
行きの列車を待っている
30人ほどのモーニングラッシュが終わったところで駅にいるのは寝坊してしまった
高校生と腰の曲がった老人だけだ
つまりのベンチでは白髪の女性が読書に夢中になっている
空は晴れ
そよ風が吹いている
自然に囲まれたこの小さな役は静か体がある
ポンポン出してしまえばいいの
がきゃりーぱみゅぱみゅのハイパー音楽を聴きつつ
カフェインたっぷりのモンスターを揉んでいる僕にはその静けさが全く味わえない
列車盗作まで10分
ポンポンウェイぽんぽん a 本いいぽんぽーん
到着まで1分
冷たい感を再び口にする
とその時視界に入る小さな開始かっけー
到着時間が迫るにつれてその四角い影がどんどん大きくなり
列車のかたちをとってくる
うぇいうぇーい開けて私の道を
列車がギーと音を立ててキャリーの声を打ち消してからホームに走り込み
そして眠そうな高校生を何人か吐き出す
彼らの間をすり抜けて列車に乗り込むと僕はリュックを下ろしてぱしこの座席に
腰掛ける
読書に夢中の老女は文字から目を外すことなく僕の方に向かって歩いていく
失敗します
よしまミラーを壁て結構申し込んでくるアイドルはいないけれど
モンスターエナジーと小説それからきゃりーぱみゅぱみゅと音質の良いん
いや方を持っている
これから1時間ほどが家で勉強ができる
村上隆のセックスティナー院を開く前に僕は眼を瞑って山のすがすがしい空気を肺 by
吸い込んだ
ここ愛鳥強い分語なまりに思わず目を開けて見上げる
塩野ヨッパ老人がニヤリと笑いながらすぐ隣の席を指差している
僕は車内を見回す
周りの席はすべて開いているのだ
あのー僕が言いかけると老人をいきなり
あり方をなと言って隣に腰掛けてきた
同時に干し草と牛の臭いが鼻をついた日本語わかるかな
返事するな返事したらおしまいだまだイヤフォンを取っていなかった僕は老人の言葉が
聞こえないふりをして慌てて iphone を取り出した
助けてきゃりーぱみゅぱみゅポンポンと老人が肩を叩いてきた
日本語わかる会を終えたの中でも遠い田舎と言われる街無人駅で日本の小説を手にして
いる僕
大げさに手を振ってノー japanese なんて言っても誰も信じてくれない
プシューと音が4ドアが閉まった
あー年寄りの話を聞くためにエナジードリンクを飲んだんじゃないのに絶望していると
窓に四角く切り取られた竹やぶがゆっくりと曲がり始め
僕は眼を瞑っていった
少しを hey これはすごいなあ大声を出して膝をとパク老人
日本長いか4年目です短く答えて視線を文字に戻す
4年目かぁどうりでうまんや
アメリカの人へ帰りたくならうのあんまり絵
音丸い老人は体を寄せてきて手を耳に当てたお兄さん国に帰りたくなるのか
あんまり再びお笑いする老人こりゃまたすごいな
やっぱり日本好きか好きです日本とアメリカ
どっちが好きどちらも好きです老人はまた爆発的に笑う
四方に唾が飛ぶ
つばの台風だ結構
と僕が思わず見上げると老人は濃霧というふうに親指と人差し指を傾けている
豚まりなんちおんマリがをんまり
老人はさらに os のジェスチャをし星稜を max にした
お酒結構飲むかいいえあんまり飲みません
大きな声でそう言って迷惑の女をロー時に向けた
するとまさかの展開を23日本語なんやな
日本長いか
4年目ですランチ4年目ですが4年目ですおにいさん結婚しちゃをしてないですねでも
もたりやろ残念ながら僕はあんたみたいなジジイにしか人気がないと言いたいのを抑え
て
と短く答える待った待った
今度一緒には酒飲むに国家お兄さん寂しいやら寂しいのもなんとの方だろ
あんまり飲まないんであんまり飲まないんでランチ会州と気づいたら
大分大学に停まっていた電車のドアが開き
年寄り夫婦が一組それから妙に色っぽい美女の団体がの離婚
てきて終わりの席を上手に埋めていく
バレエシューズを持っている者もいるあんまり飲まないんで若い頃の花と愛にとても
よく似たキレイなお姉さんが目の前の座席にそっと腰掛け
そしてゆっくりと長い脚を来た一瞬
老人から立ち上っていた牧場の臭いが消えたコード一緒に温泉に行こうか
23人人で計あろう
スゴ台風ステージつ10:20
三重町と比べればネオ東京である大分に到着すると
英検英検と言いながら電話番号押し付けてくる老人にちょっと急いでますのでと別れを
つけて人混みに飛び込む
そしてきゃりーぱみゅぱみゅと最初
シンクロをし出口に向かって歩いていくつけまつけるかなんだか無性に美しく聞こえる
しばらく歩いているとそうかボケた老人には音楽をより美しくする能力があるなと変に
納得するモンスターが聴いていて気持ちがいい
無意識のうちにハイテンションもビートに歩調を合わせ改築されたばかり
の騒がしい駅を取り抜けていく時折老人に追われていないかとさりげなく後ろを
振り返る
新しい改札を出て見回すと右手の大きな柱についている
まるでスターウォーズにでも出てきそうな液晶案内板にビックリしそこに
スターバックスが乗っていないことに一段と衣装疲れる
とに出るといつもにか曇った空と mac の匂いがする空気になんだか憂鬱になる
あすぐそこよと道を教えてくれたおばさんの指示に従って歩き出すバスと飛行機それ
から何か
丸くて緑色のものが描かれた看板が見えてくる
近づくにつれてそれが多い
のマスコットキャラクターでやる鳥のメジロんぱと分かった
羽のついたライムみたいだ
時々田舎の人のセンスがわからなくなる
バス停前の自販機で乗車券と缶コーヒーを買い
またもいつ潰れてもおかしくないプラスチックベンチに座って
小説を取り出す村上龍の口方向時代の話に人っているとバスは
という間に当地
福祉ポークは
慌ててポケットを探ってから調査権を本のしおりにしていることを思い出し
立ち上がってすいませんと栄杓すると顔はから見たまま
狭い度をくぐって席に着いたローなく出発居場所
よし
結構申し込んでくる看護婦に囲まれてはいないけれど
観光1小節それからきゃりーぱみゅぱみゅとも質の良いイヤホンを塗っている
これから1時間ほどが家で勉強に励める
フォン再び開く前に僕は眼を瞑ってマックの空気を肺いっぱい吸い込んだ
ここをいいですかふと見上げると
いつから室もうやってるんですかと思わず聞いてしまいそうなほど太ったおっさんが目
の前に立っている
僕は辺りを見回す
誰もいない
誰一人いないのだあのおっさんは後ろから乗り込んでくるきゃ香味やって一瞬にして汗
をかきだし
ごめんごめんと言って突如隣に腰を掛けた
横ロッシュ横綱が座るとバスはかぬみたいに左右に揺れ
何か柔らかくて温かいものが僕の太ももに当たった
高知付と唇を噛み読書に意識を集中するがそうしているうちになんだか
とても妙な気分になるあたかもまじまじと見つめられているかのような気分
すごいの日本で最もよく使われている戦術
日本語を勉強している外国人に直接話しかけるのが強いため
すごいのとかふぅ
絵とかうーんとか言って相手が何ですか
と反応するまでしばらくわけのわからない発言をする
騙されるか
僕は視線を窓の外にやり
小説を投じてバックパックに入れうーんうーんすごいの
それから iphone を取り出して音量ほぼ max にした
高田目立った男は太い指で僕のリュックを刺した
日本語読めるんですかこれからの会話
日本の小説を止めるなんてすごいですねそういえばこれをすごく偶然なんですが僕を実
は良い棒を勉強していて今外国人の友達を作る
んあ
学校の先生ですかいやーこんなところでへぇ語の先生にお供なかパパ枚から
緊張しすぎて全然話せませんであっ大分に住んでるんですね
よかったら今度スターバックスに行っていとしのキャラメラってもみませんか
少しは土木が答えたすると男はニヤリと笑った
貰っパッって表情している日本を動いですね長いんですか日本は4年目です
英語の先生とかやってるんですかまずいこのままじゃ完全に飲み込まれてしまう
いや違います留学生ですかこれはすごく偶然なんですが僕は実はアメリカに留学したく
て今外国人のキム8を作るさせるか
いや違います男は再び死亡いらした
日本に英会話の先生と留学生以外に若い白人がいるので信じられないと
増のにをしてるんですかと言いたげに僕の言葉を繰り返した
違うんですかしかし残念ながら僕はまだ
偽の職業思いついていなかった
なぜかというと日本にはいい買い物先生と留学生以外に若い白人がほとんどいないから
だ僕は
2階はなきゃ何かうまいこと言わないといやーほんと偶然ですね僕達って兄弟じゃない
なんて言われそうだ
僕はやそのはい僕は落ち着け
9考える日本で何をしてらっしゃるんですか
俳優です男はそっと黙り込んだ本当ですか
はい year
彼はそう言って太い手を口に当てふふと笑っぱなんですか
と僕は思わず引っかかったこれはすごく偶然なんですが僕は実派俳優を目指していって
今俳優や
アクターの友達を作ろうとしてるんですよもしよかったら友だちになりませんか
これが僕の0
も番号です下水金は1日と日は午後から開いてますので
男はそう言ってまたニヤリと笑ったその不気味な映画を見ているうちに
しまった
と思ったが遅かった僕はという間に4ケタ脂肪に飲み込まれると
12:00
ば sorry 友達からの電話でなんとか横綱を土俵の外に押し出すと僕はもう
ダーシでおいた空港に走り込み
直接ゲートに行きそれからまわりを気にしながら最も搭乗口に近いベンチに座って読書
を始めた文字を追うにつれて緊張はどんどんほぐれていき
叩く間に時が過ぎたふと気づくとセックス t 内のチャラい主人公になりきった僕が
羽田空港の青い制服を着た可愛い案内スタッフをちらちら見ていた
しかし小説を片手に歩いているとまたいつのまにか
活人吸い込まれ眠りにつく寸前のように互換元に打っていく
次に
気付いたときは三重町と同じ惑星とは思えないコンクリートジャングルの東京を押す
長いバスでぬように走っていた窓の外を見るとスカイツリーという大分では大半の人が
ぱどの作り話にすぎないと主張する
糞高いタワーがそびえ立っているそれを iphone をしに眺めつつ
僕は1分ほどブレた写真を撮りまくるそして一番綺麗なの角に編集し
露光という無性にかっこいい紫色のフィルターをつけてから
ああ東京様と言うコメントとともに facebook と twitter に
アップする
きゃりぱ新曲キャンディキャンディの単純さに陶酔しつつ
歓談中襲ってくるいい年を確認しているとバスは成田空港ターミナル2についた
wii ヘッジで笑みを浮かべた綺麗なじゃろうね s
の自然な英語を聞いていると想像が膨らんでいく
一般の日本人に比べると発音は神様レベルだがどうしても帰国子女とは思えない大学
時代に留学でもしたのだろう
アクセントから察するとアメリカの西海岸に行ったらしい
きっとカリフォルニアに切ったんだ
おそらくそのフランシスカ想定お姉さんは多分
菌門橋には何度も言っただろうけれど
アルカトラズ島はどうだうーん今度行こうねまあでも貼っせることがないからね
何度も友達に言ったものの
2か月も経たないうちによっ系というフィンランドからやってきた
別の留学生と付き合い始め
いつのまにかあっつの青目に心を奪われてしまい彼とアパートに閉じこもって一緒に
ファメ利害を見たりやすいと元ソースのかかったスパゲッティを食べたり
ずっと一緒にいようねー
と百束したいしたにも関わらずやはり
サンフランシスコを発つ日が迫るにつれて同氏はどうしようと少しずつファンになり
そのうちに
玉形に嫌われて振られてしまい気づいたら帰りの飛行機の小さな窓から
アルカトラズとを眺めていて言ってもないのにあの須磨区て詰めた
特防にいるように感じるのはなぜなんだろう
と思いながら今度こそいこうと
涙目をクスってつぶやいたに違いないパブグッズ5 x ゲートに到着すると僕は独尊
ならー機内でいい体もできる
とベンチに寝そべって iphone を取り出し
さんなこと言っておいて端玉映画ばかり見るくせにと心の中で思いながらあのグリー
バーズをして時間をつぶし始めた
そのうちに搭乗が始まり僕は立ち上がってさりげなく列に割り込んだしを取るに
ロメオるのこの
一そりゃないだろと笑いを交わす中学生らしい5人組とだから水を買って受けていった
と小声で喧嘩をする外国人カップルに挟まれている
ゲートを抜けると飛行機は始めたらしい中学生はひふへ
やめよでと盛り上がっていき外国人カップルは
あめっちゃまずいからと機内食について
ブツブツ言い出した僕はこっそりと両手合わせて目をつぶり
お願いだからつまりがおっさんじゃありませんようにとひたすら祈っていると
ワークもボールまた綺麗な jal お姉さんに言われ
どうもぺー酌するそして搭乗券を見ながら飛行機の多くに向かって歩き始める
搭乗券と座席の番号がマッチしたところで反射的に足を止めて森を観察する魔導石で
前にはスーツを着たインド g 6ぽい弾ず描いて後ろには見るからに韓国人観光客と
いた集団が座っている
隣にはまだ誰もいないそれをしただけで
おろしたての靴下を履く時みたいに単純な興奮に包まれたが腰をかけて通路の方を見た
瞬間
ん喜ぶのは早いと再び強烈な緊張感にとらわれる
やってくるのは
おっさんばかりだ汗で手がてかせる彼らの額を見ていると喉がカラカラになりつい
呼吸が荒くなるルーすごいのはシアトルの人ですかほ特使は今から3ヶ月シアトルに
行くんですがあんまりアメリカウィング利子に自信がなくてそれできないで本当に
申し訳ありませんが少し
火曜のプラッ p そうしてもいいですかねぇこういうチャンスで滅多にないですから
ところでスターバックスを好きですかよかったら今度一緒に1号店に行って抹茶フラペ
でもみませんか
肌を振れていた目の焦点を合わせて顔をあげ
思わずまばたきする三村さ
通路に立って笑みを浮かべたキャッシュの女性を見てそうも彼女は細い唇をゆっくり
動かした
アヌマイスイーさあ早く座って why を飲みませんか
映画は何がいいですか本当に僕もロマンス系が大好きなんですよ空戦すぎる
ところで君は本当に英語が上手いですねや教師としてか
元気ですねあっそうそう僕は英語の教師なんですよ
シアトルに付いたらスターバックスの1号店でプライベートレッスンでもいかが
でしょうか
アッサーっと答え落ち着け落ち着け落ち着け
胸躍らせながらミス日本の玉座にうっかりおいてしまった力を自分の足下に移したが
そうすると今度は
自分の手をどこに置けばいいかわからなくなり慌ててポケットに突っ込んだ
これで完璧と思ったか彼女がつまりにそっと座ってみるとパケットをやっぱり変だなー
と考え治し方もの肘を窓にもたせかけ
もう片方の腕をさりげなく肘掛けに乗せた
作戦開始
あーゆーすとりーにんぐしゅミス日本はびっくりしたように綺麗な魔除け理由こっちを
向いた
アメロべばいっ
楚辺コロンずは少しだけというふうに空気を撮
そう言って恥ずかしそうに笑っパニュスタグある
ウォーリー doner 恩田ステイ塩水 siden バーへといった彼女は美しい
指を広げてバレーらーシージェスチャをシェ
ばはにかんで笑ったとその瞬間
1僕はカルマ教の信者になった
これだこれまで100人以上のおっさんと付き合ってきたの
このためなのだディ my fire すけねえ3個 mice ちみーちゅー
hemi 今
imanam ないすとぅーみーちゅーちゅーやんじゃあ僕たちは同時に微笑みん
また同時に方わからねぇそして再び笑って視線を逸らした
その時だったすみません問3のまま
ふと見上げる思わず顔がこわばった通路にツルツル頭のサイズの合っていないスーツを
着たおっさんが立っているそこを僕の席なんですが彼はそう言って腐ったホットドッグ
みたいな醜い指でミス日本の玉座を刺した
いみちゃん今から男同士でちょっと話をするから待っててねと僕が様としたがそれより
早く彼女は本当ですか
と席名刺素早くチケットを取り出した
そして申し訳ありませんと事業して優雅さを失うことなく荷物をまとめて立ち上がると
ツールを渡り
版パイが
の座席に腰を下ろした nonono のフェイスブックとかやってますか
僕は貴方としたが僕の言葉はおっさんの中に遮られてしまった
そうってと世界一憎らしいを押さはそう言って悠然と僕の隣に座り
すぐさま間違った英語を使っていませんか
た書かれた青い品
を取り出したそして堂々と朗読し始めた
僕は上田ですコーヒーを一緒に飲みませんか
my name is 上田 do do you how time for
コーフィー
んんやっぱりグラマをレビューしようかなぁ
鍵上田はそう言って自分の生ぬるくて重くて毛深い腕を僕の腕の上に乗せた
おっと付総理総理総理じゃねーよ早く実物改正法
と思いながら
夏酒と短く答えいや方へと手を伸ばした
上田は即座に台に攻撃を開始したあああいうフローんシアトル僕は伸ばすた腕を戻し
力なくヘッドレストに頭をもたせかけた
そしてゆっくりと目を瞑った
やす
sm フェア成田からシアトルまでのフライトは11時間
その間ずっと僕はミス日本の大きな優しい目
それから
シートベルトが人殺しの道具になるというアイロニーについて思いを巡らしたん
me